wir sollten die Chance mal nutzen weil
sie auch heute hier sind mal zu
verstehen wie das wirklich alles
begonnen hat
wo sind aus ihrer Sicht sozusagen die
Momente an denen das ganze
plötzlich in eine völlig falsche
Richtung läuft sie sagt eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle spielt sozusagen die
die Einreise über die DDR
interessanterweise ja auf alle Fälle
also wie hat das funktioniert wie ist
das begonnen und wir reden ja immer noch
eine Frage wir sagen immer libanesische
Clans
weil es sind nicht im klassischen Sinne
Libanesen das sind keine Libanesen
sondern das sind man nennt sie halami
Gruppe aus der Südost Türkei die in den
Libanon in den
30er Jahren eingewandert sind der
Libanon war damals ich weiß das Orients
um zu leben im Libanon würden sie nie
akzeptiert und daher lebten sie in
Ghettos und waren auf
[Musik]
ihre Familie aufeinander angewiesen und
da haben sie ihre siebten Strukturen
weiter aufgebaut sie dürfen nicht
arbeiten die Schule besuchen die könnte
vom Konsum Gesundheitswesen nicht
profitieren und daher wird ist die alte
Struktur die mitgebrachte Struktur auf
dem Südost Türkei noch stärker geworden
verstehen und wann wann beginnt ja auch
nicht das war glaube ich der
der Schritt in Deutschland auch immer
falsch gemacht hat dass da eben keine
Schulpflicht war für für Kinder dieser
Familien das ist kein Recht gehabt zu
arbeiten also richtig
erwerbsberuf zu haben und dass das eben
im Grunde perpetuiert worden ist dann
eben nach der zweiten Station
aber der Hintergrund dafür ist die
Tatsache
das ist sie als nach Deutschland kamen
das waren die ersten
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge und für die
deutschen das war fremd
und wir reden jetzt von
den 80er Jahre oder von wann reden wir
im Libanon hat im April 75 angefangen
und die ersten großen Gruppen
erschienen im Jahre 76 also ziemlich
schnell und die haben den Weg nach
Westberlin gefunden über Palästinenser
die schon
den Weg kannten weil viele
palästinenserfahrung Studenten in der
der und die Peru genau warum verbündet
und diese da hat Stipendien gegeben und
die Ballisten bekannten diese weg da kam
mir vereinzelt schon Flüchtlinge aus dem
Leben über diesen Weg aber die Masse kam
mit dem Bürgerkrieg und der Schienen im
da waren also mein erster Kontakt mit
denen wir hatten einen Verein
Hilfe und die Flüchtlinge im Libanon zu
unterstützen und dann wurden wir von den
Behörden angerufen also von den Ämtern
nach dem Motto wir haben eine neue
Gruppe mit anderen Sprache metalität ob
wir helfen können da bin ich das war in
Kreuzberg ich bin dahin gegangen und da
fand ich vor mir ca 300 Personen aber
das waren keine libaneser das war dem
Halle wie das war mein erster Kontakt
mit denen und dann ging es weiter so wie
ging es dann weiter sie sagen
ein zentrales Stichwort das Leben ist ja
manchmal ganz einfach ist das Stichwort
Supermarkt
ja
sie kamen in Berlin
die wurde nicht akzeptiert und die
wurden nicht anerkannt als politisch
Verfolgte
genießen Asien da Artikel 6c weil sie
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge waren und
politisch verfolgt heißt man ist vom
Staat verfolgt und hat keine
Ausweichmöglichkeiten bei Bürgerkriegen
haben die Gerichte immer entschieden ja
wenn es in eine Ecke knallt dann kann
man sich in eine andere Ecke bewegt
begeben und wurde nicht angekommen so
man könnte sie aber nicht abschieben
wegen der Genfer Konvention
Flüchtlinge Konversion und so sind sie
als geduldete im Belege geblieben jetzt
was unser Problematik betrifft
Berlin war ein offener Stadt also wie in
Europa das war ein offener Gesellschaft
und die kamen aus der Beirut die kleine
Kriminalität begann gerade aber sie wie
sie sagen im Supermarkt alles klar herum
im Libanon damals gab es ein einziger
Supermarkt in Beirut das Spinne ist es
und das war für die Europäer gedacht
damit die Deutschen ihre schwarze Brot
kaufen können
aber für den besten sehr und hier liegt
alles rum und ich habe einfach die
Sachen mitgenommen
da begann damals dieses
Sicherheitsdienst in den Supermärkten
begann langsam also da wurden Leute der
erste Moment in dem Supermärkte dann
anfingen zu sagen Sicherheitsleute
einzustellen ja es ist vorher nicht
brauchte
72 und da gab es nichts ja und nach
diesem da kommen diese
Flüchtlinge dann müssen sie sich
beschützen die Supermärkte oder
Sicherheitsdienst überall und
in meinem Beratungsstelle zum Beispiel
mit der
kontaktbeamter gab es damals zu Fuß hat
die Leute gefragt wie es geht und der
erzählte mir dass die alte Leute die
machen einen kleinen Geschäft
dass sie kurz vor dem Bankrott sind also
die können den Diebstahl nicht mehr
durch eben
große kompensieren also da in diese
kleinen Läden da kommen zum Beispiel
fünf sechs Leute auf einmal da verliert
er den Überblick er wird von einem
beschäftigt und so hat es angefangen so
als angefangen und einen Punkt will ihn
noch gerne machen er ärgert man sie
sagen wenn man das verstehen will was da
sozusagen also
psychologisch auch passiert da muss man
darüber reden dass man so in der Gruppe
Auftritt das ist ganz wichtig zu
verstehen dass diese Gruppe aus dieser
Gruppe heraus auch dieses Gefühl
entsteht wir sind sozusagen unser
eigenes Rechte unser eigenes Gesetz und
wir stehen über dem Gesetz des Landes in
dem wir gerade sind warum ist dieser
gruppengedanke so wichtig ja das war das
Ergebnis also irgendwann haben Sie
gemerkt dass ihre klaren Solidarität die
sie mitgebracht haben
sehr nützlich sein kann in unseren
individualisierten Gesellschaft wenn sie
als rudert auftreten da können Sie jeden
auseinander nehmen die haben bei den
Einzelpersonen angefangen
und dann haben sie entdeckte sie mit dem
Schutzsystem etwas beginnen können
ich nenne ein Beispiel da kommen drei
Leute von ihnen
getrennt zwei zusammen und der dritte in
einem Restaurant oder Bar und äh der
dritte macht Krach und die anderen
nehmen ihn und weil sie ihr raus und ich
verstehe der Besitzer ist dankbar und
denkt ja bieten ihren Schutz okay eine
Summe und nachher hat sich das
entwickelt das ist so weit gesehen dass
jeder der ein Geschäft in ihrem Viertel
aufmachte musste Schutzgeld bezahlen
also da die die
das alles habe ich gesehen in dieser
Phase und demand reagierte darauf ich
glaube das ist ja auch so ein
eigentlichen Merkmal von vor
industriellen und vor demokratischen
Gesellschaft nicht das hat man ja in
Süditalien mit der Mafia ganz ähnliche
Struktur gibt ein wunderbaren Roman der
das auch erklärt hat der Leopard von
Lampedusa in dem im so klar wird warum
Clanstrukturen in Gesellschaften in
denen es keine Rechtssicherheit gibt in
denen es auch keine
Versorgungssicherheit gibt eben auch ein
überlebensmerkmal für Familien sind und
die eben dann natürlich abgelöst werden
müssen in dem Moment wo man eben dann in
einer entwickelten Gesellschaft ist oder
in einer Gesellschaft ist in der eben
das Gewaltmonopol des Staates oder
Rechtssicherheit eben eine sehr sehr
große Rolle spielen das zu Duden und zu
sehen dass man es eben nicht ablöst und
eben auch nicht dann lässt und das
betrifft ja eben nicht nur arabische
Clans sondern eben auch auch die Mafia
oder die Gitter das ist glaube ich das
kann man überhaupt nicht schön also die
Mafia ist mit den Klassen nicht zu
vergleichend man redet die Rede von
Familie aber in dieser Familie können
nicht verwandte auch aufgenommen werden
oder da kann man auch aussteigen bei den
Clans ist es nicht gegeben der was
Bindeglied ist das Blut also die sind
alle Verwandtschaft und das ist ein
Schwierigkeit für die Polizei die kann
sie nie unterwandern wenn sie dich und
zusammenhalten da gibt's keine und das
machen sie überall das machen sie
überall wenn man sie verhaftet dann
kommt nichts raus total interessanter
Punkt weil wir gerade da sind auf jeder
sagte gerade das stimmt wir reden auch
gleich darüber aber letzter Punkt noch
sie sagen der zweite große Fehler etwas
was wir nie verstanden haben politisch
nicht richtig bewertet haben ist
Familiennachzug
der deutschen Politik sagen sie war
nicht klar welche Konsequenzen das
wirklich hat
Familienzusammenführung Familiennachzug
warum ja also
weil weil einem bestimmte Wissenschaft
in Deutschland nicht existiert die
kulturelle und sozialen unter
Anthropologie das ist eine Wissenschaft
die die
kulturellen Hintergrund untersucht und
die gibt's nicht bei uns wenn Sie einen
Blick auf die
Wissenschaftler die im Migrationsbereich
steht sind sind hauptsächlich zum großen
Teil Soziologen und keine Anthropologen
und daher fällt diese Forschung und als
ich meine Forschung angefangen habe da
habe ich nichts gemacht
es gab ein einziges Studio über
Sizilianer in Frankfurt und der nicht
und das erste Buch in diese Richtung in
der deutschen Sprache ist 2003 in
Österreich erschienen und heißt
islamische
Stammesgesellschaft wurde die
Untersuchung und die Problematik aber in
Deutschland existiert diese Wissenschaft
nicht und sie sagen wir machen uns keine
Vorstellung davon wie groß so eine
Familie dann wirklich werden kann ja
weil diese Wissenschaft nicht vorhanden
ist wie viele Menschen reden wir dann ja
also
man muss davon ausgehen erstmal das die
meisten Flüchtlinge die zu uns kommen
also Migranten ja die kommen aus dem
Gebiet von von Nordafrika und nach dem
Osten also von Marokko bis Afghanistan
und in diesem Gebiet gerade hat diese
Wissenschaft der Kultur Anthropologie
ein die Familie untersucht also diese
Wissenschaft beschäftigt sich mit klaren
Stämme und so weiter und die haben
entdeckt das in diesem Gebiet die
Großfamilie die Großfamilie in ihrer
verschiedenen Formen die
zentrale Einheit für die soziale
Organisation dort weil wir sie gesagt
haben
Wohlfahrt startet dort nicht existieren
und das Individuum ist auf seine Familie
und Großfamilie angewiesen in alle
Lebenslagen also jederzeit Kindheit
Arbeitslosigkeit Alter und so weiter und
mit dieser Struktur kommen Sie zu uns
und man hat das nicht gesehen wie viele
Menschen wie groß kann das sein
eine große Familie wie viele Menschen
kann die umfassen
die Großfamilie oder die Gesellschaft
ja jetzt haben müssen
der Plan ist ein Verband von Leute die
verwandtschaftlich gebunden sind wenn
verschiedene klagen behaupten oder
glauben dass sie ein einzigen Ahnen
haben dann bildet sich ein Stamm und
wenn wir von Stämme reden
die können
ich meine
manchmal bis 50.000 Mitglieder haben
also die gesamte Arabien zum Beispiel
wenn man die Karte sieht ist zwischen
300 Stämme aufgeteilt das ganze Land mit
ihrem Gebieten und so weiter und daher
muss man sehen
verstanden
36 Millionen Einwohner ungefähr sowas
habe ich im Kopf
wenn eine Großfamilie kommt wenn wir
über sehr viele Menschen sprechen dann
müssen die Leute ja nicht
notwendigerweise eine kriminell sein
aber offensichtlich können sich sehr
leicht kriminelle Strukturen
herausfinden wir haben gerade gehört wie
das
unter Umständen entsteht
sehr vieler sind ja nicht nur
Kriminalhauptkommissar sondern auch
aufgewachsen genau in der Gegend über
die wir gerade auch sprechen wie haben
sie das wahrgenommen in ihrer jugendther
heute mit einem Freund gesprochen der
sagte kommt dass da gleich eine Ecke
sagte ich erinnere mich wie es plötzlich
im Jugendzentrum anders wurde wie
plötzlich Schlägereien an der
Tagesordnung war wie plötzlich andere
Gesetze gehalten wir plötzlich
Teenager auftraten und sagten pass mal
auf jetzt geht's hier um mich mein
Freund drei vier Libanesen mehr waren
das nicht
sagen also die Maßstäbe sind da noch ein
bisschen andere gewesen jedenfalls in
meiner Erinnerung ich komme auch aus dem
kleineren Teil des Ruhrgebiets Wetter an
der Uhr das ist jetzt keine Großstadt
wie wir essen beispielsweise wo man
Wahlkreis jetzt liegt und da waren die
Dimensionen schon noch anders aber ich
kenne kann mich durchaus an einzelne
Episoden erinnern die so ein bisschen
darauf hindeuten was sie gerade sagten
also dass man zumindest Konflikte
durchaus mit Gewalt Ausdruck daran habe
ich durchaus auch Erinnerungen in der
Vergangenheit deswegen würde ich jetzt
aber nicht zwingend sagen oder weiß das
auch nicht ob das Teile solche
Strukturen gewesen sind über die wir
jetzt heute sprechen da wäre ich weit
von das hat sich dann offenbar was
anderes um die Frage dann wie konnte
sich
diese diese diese diese diese ganze
Struktur so verbreiten diese
Kriminalität so verbreiten ohne dass
irgendjemand eingreift jemand werden
auch in den 70er 80er 90er Jahren hatten
wir auch eine Polizei
die öffentliche Ordnung in diesem Land
die die bestand ja ich habe ja gerade
schon versucht darauf hinzuweisen ist ja
nicht so aber dieses Gefühl sozusagen
für alles Verständnis zu haben niemals
zu sagen pass auf das ist aber hier die
rote Linie das geht so nicht ich komme
aus dem Kriegsgebiet die Menschen sind
traumatisiert wir müssen das verstehen
auch wenn Schlägereien gibt auch wenn es
ganz offenkundig Dinge gibt die völlig
aus dem Ruder laufen wenn der Kleine
Supermarkt überfallen wird was auch
immer
wann ist uns das so aus dem Ruder
gelaufen wann konnte man sozusagen die
offensichtlichen Dinge nicht mehr klar
benennen und sie dann auch konsequent
bekämpfen ich würde das Pferd aus einer
anderen Richtung aufzeigen und nochmal
darauf hinweisen dass die Probleme ja
auf dem Tisch gelegen haben spätestens
2004 als die Kripo sich zusammengesetzt
hat aufgeschrieben hat wie die Probleme
aussehen und welche Konzepte eigentlich
erforderlich sind und die entscheidende
Frage lautet aus meiner Sicht warum hat
die Politik danach in den vielen Jahren
nicht daran an diesen Konzepten
gearbeitet und meine leidenhafte Analyse
ist die wenn ich mich zurück erinnere
und für mich für mich war so ein
bisschen so ein Wendepunkt der
öffentlichen Debatte die Silvester nach
zwei 15-2016 wenn ich mich zurück
erinnere sie mögen das aus der
Mediensicht mögen widersprechen oder das
bestätigen weil die öffentlichen Debatte
davor und danach eine andere ich glaube
in der öffentlichen Debatte war sehr
sehr schwierig davor und zwar völlig
parteiübergreifend und das galt nach
meiner Erinnerung auch in der
Medienlandschaft ich habe mich mit
Journalistin Journalisten unterhalten
die mir berichtet haben das ist sehr
schwer gewesen ist in Radiosendung zu
thematisieren wie die Probleme dort
Aussehen in diesen Teilen der
Migrationsgesellschaft die dort zu uns
gekommen sind über die wir jetzt gerade
hier heute sprechen das ist ein Teil der
Wahrheit und deswegen glaube ich ist es
fast eine logische Konsequenz dass ich
Innenminister egal welcher
Farbgebung in der Vergangenheit nicht
getraut haben wahrscheinlich die
Probleme so offensiv anzugehen wie das
zum Beispiel bei der Rocker Kriminalität
durchaus passiert ist da gibt's nämlich
durchaus insoweit parallelen als dass
die Konzepte zu Bekämpfung dieser
Kriminalität teilweise identisch sind
wie sie heute auch tatsächlich fort
entwickelt werden also Kurzfassung ist
meine küchenanalyse ist wir haben in der
öffentlichen Debatte uns nicht getraut
und zwar allesamt die Dinge so beim
Namen zu nennen wie sehr ergibt man
damals schon aufgeschrieben hat und das
Politik tatsächlich auch diesen
Handlungsdruck von außen benötigt das
erlebe ich jetzt in meiner noch jungen
Bundestag Erfahrung durchaus
und ich glaube dazu kommt eben auch dass
man der Polizei halt auch nicht getraut
hat nicht also wenn die Polizei gesagt
hat wir haben hier ein Problem wir
müssen uns darum kümmern hat man eben
zunächst mal gefragt wer sagt das
eigentlich und aus welcher aus welcher
Position heraus und es gibt eben einfach
jedenfalls in Westdeutschland seit den
80er Jahren spätestens 70er Jahren eben
einfach auch wenn man sehr sehr großes
Misstrauen gegenüber Polizisten und eben
deren Einschätzung von lagen
also da habe ich überhaupt keine
Erinnerung nee also
1993 bei der Polizei angefangen und dann
solche Debatten kann ich mich in diesem
Ausmaß überhaupt nicht erinnern ganz im
Gegenteil die sind er Teil der jüngeren
Vergangenheit glaube ich aber die
Zeichnung die wir jetzt reden Multikulti
als als gesellschaftlich
dass man deswegen die Themen nicht
angepackt hätte weil man der Polizei
nicht getraute das ist allein deswegen
schon unlogisch weil sich ja innerhalb
des Bund Länder gefü Videos eben die
Polizei in zusammengesetzt haben und
Konzepte erarbeitet haben die Frage ist
warum sie politisch anschließend nicht
umgesetzt worden sind hätte nach meiner
Einschätzung nichts damit zu tun dass
man dass der Polizei nicht zugetraut hat
sondern es ist etwas ganz anderes man
sagt dazu man muss kriminalstrategische
Schwerpunkte setzen so das bestimmen die
jeweiligen Landesregierungen vorwiegend
das ist nur ein Ausschnitten Teile des
Bundes sondern die Landesregierung
bestimmen welche kriminalstrategischen
Schwerpunkte jeweils besetzt werden wo
man besonders Ressourcen reinsteckt
welche man besonders klar arbeiten will
und dann muss offensichtlich gemacht
ihre Erklärung warum hatte man nicht und
und er hat ja völlig recht ich erinnere
mich Robin alexander hat glaube ich
dieser Tage noch mal darauf hingewiesen
die Kollegen von SPIEGEL TV z.B die
haben eine ganze Weile sehr gut
recherchiert ganz Kamerateams die da
immer wieder in diese schwierigen
Situationen rein sind immer wieder bei
kleinen Kriminalität auch berichtet
haben und ich erinnere mich daran mit
diesen diesen Verein die neuen deutschen
Medienmacher die haben den dann die
goldene Kartoffel dafür verliehen so
nach dem Motto was ist das für ein für
ein diskriminierendes Zeug was sie hier
so berichtet das war unsere jetzige das
hat die diskriminierungsbeauftragt ja
aber
die hat das gemacht ja man kann aber
auch über Frau Widmann Mauzi in dem
Zusammenhang sprechen also und deswegen
ist der Befund so richtig alle
gleichermaßen mit CDU
Integrationsbeauftragte die diesen
Verein gefördert hat der dann die
goldene Kartoffel verleiht ich will nur
sagen dass ein ganzes großes System des
wegguckens und nicht wissen wollen was
da eigentlich passiert ist wie geht ihre
Erklärung dafür wollen das also
in den 90er Jahren nach dem Fall der
Mauer
war die Ausländerfeindlichkeit so enorm
und da gab es diese diese Überfälle
Rostock hoyerswerke
Solingen ja und die Öffentlichkeit war
erschrocken und da dann hat sie reagiert
mit
Lichterketten von Ulm nach München
Demo in Berlin mit über 300.000 Menschen
zurecht und damit hat sich die Ideologie
vom Multikulti durchgesetzt
das glaube ich nicht also ich glaube da
muss man schon sehr klar unterscheiden
dass man sich dagegen wehrt und dagegen
auf die Straße geht wenn Ausländer
überfallen werden wenn
Migrationsfamilien ermordet werden das
gehört glaube ich zu einer
demokratischen zivilgesellschaftlichen
Kultur die man eben nicht in den Kontext
setzen darf zu wir haben über Probleme
hinweg gesehen das glaube ich ist muss
man schon respektieren in der vorbei
ergattern wollte gerade glaube ich einen
anderen Punkt machen ne ihm geht es um
den Begriff Multikulti so habe ich das
verstanden
zurück in den 80er Jahren
in der 80er Jahren hat es heftige
Debatten über Ausländer aber total seit
82 es gibt soweit ich weiß nicht ob man
sich noch an den Heidelbergern Manifest
von swantastisch erinnert
unterschrieben von deutsche Professoren
mit ganz klare völkische und
rassistische Unterton gegen die
Migration und als Reaktion gab es diese
in der Zivilgesellschaft vor allem die
die waren noch nicht grün ich kann mich
aus meiner Erfahrung Berlin die
Alternative Liste hat dagegen gehalten
und nachher nach dem Fall der Mauer als
das Phänomen enorm war der
hauptverteidiger von von Multikulti da
das war der CDU Mann der Geißler also
Multikulti wenn Sie denken das ist eine
linke Politik es ist keine linke Politik
die war quer durch alle Parteien und
wegen dieser Ereignisse hat sich diese
Ideologie durchgesetzt die habe gesagt
Leute wir machen Gründen Tische und wir
führen ein Dialog mit allen Parteien und
dann noch nicht den Rechtsstaat außer
Kraft setzen können
und dann haben sie gesagt wir müssen die
Minderheiten nicht diskriminieren und
die Politik hat mitgemacht mit
Anweisungen die Polizei war es war der
Polizei verboten
verboten ich betone das dass sie die die
ethnische Zugehörigkeit von den
Straftäter zu erwähnen und da deshalb
sage ich die 90er Jahren war ein
Paradies da könnten sie sich entfalten
gerade diese Gruppen also die Clans weil
man sie nicht gesehen hat
vereinzelt die Polizei war mit deiner
konfrontiert aber es war verboten in dem
berichten und so weiter jetzt in Berlin
wollten sie die Leute abschieben die
haben die
igeiden für die Identifizierung der
Leute geschaffen und dann haben sie
entdeckt dass alle zu einer Gruppe der
gehört
also das war die erste
Erfassung sozusagen der der Gruppe dann
wechselte die Regierung in Berlin und
die haben die Gruppe aufgelöst und die
neue Regierung hat das verboten es war
verboten die letzte LKA Bericht von 2010
da besteht drin wir erwähnen die
Minderheiten nicht wir sprechen von
Menschen mit arabischen Hintergrund und
unter arabischen Hintergrund
bedeutet die Arabische Liga und das sind
22 Ländern also der Polizist der handeln
will muss auch die Sau die die Leute und
die Emirat Leute
Sicht haben das heißt die können nicht
effektiv sein und in diesem Bericht
wieder da um die Zahlen der Plan zu
erfassen da beziehen ich werde zitiert
mit den Zahlen ich war total empört das
ist ein Zahl die ich Anfang der 90er
Jahren erwähnt habe und die wird im Jahr
2010 in einem lka-bericht erwähnt damit
Sie wissen was die Behörde gemacht hat
das war eine politische Entscheidung
unter dem Einfluss von multikum ich habe
Einfluss von Multikulti ich muss das
noch einmal ganz kurz versuchen ein
bisschen begrifflich zu klären wir haben
nur noch ein paar Minuten her viele ich
habe viel gelesen über Herrn gattmann er
sagt multikulti ist als Ideologie wie es
nennt gescheitert hat weil er sagt
Multikulti bedeutet wir wir existieren
sozusagen alle nebeneinander her aber
wir einigen uns nicht auf eine
gemeinsame Basis jeder macht quasi Seins
und er sagt der bessere Begriff wäre
Pluralismus was bedeutet wir sind zwar
alle hier aber es ist klar unter welchen
Prämissen das alles läuft und auf dieses
Grundgesetz für uns verständigen und das
nicht jeder sein Ding macht ich glaube
an dem Punkt sind wir heute auch
deutlich weiter noch mal zum Schluss
trotzdem die Frage nach den Konsequenzen
also das muss man ja tatsächlich trennen
also ich habe deswegen jetzt auch ein
paar Mal wirklich schwer geatmet weil
ich jetzt wirklich so die die gesamte
Integrationsdebatte und die Betrachtung
sozusagen wie man auf der anderen Seite
eben durchaus noch mal ansprechen darf
dass wir echt ein heftiges
Rechtsextremismus Probleme haben ich
darf noch mal kurz auf die
Umfrageergebnisse in bestimmten Teilen
der Republik hinweisen was wir dafür ein
riesen Aufgabenpaket haben das darf man
jetzt schon noch dazu erzählen wenn wir
aufpassen müssen welche Erzählungen wir
jetzt hier so verbreiten AFD versucht
übrigens mit Konzepten von vom Bund
Deutscher Kriminal beim anderen damit
Politik zu machen deswegen auch ehrlich
machen
denn wir müssen noch mal klarer darüber
sprechen über welche Kriminalität
Phänomene wir hier diskutieren und was
dazu tun ist und da reicht es eben nicht
und das kann ich jetzt auch nicht fahren
weil das in den letzten Tagen natürlich
immer wieder Thema ist diese Politik der
1000 nadelschiche ist gescheitert so das
muss man eben sagen das sehen wir anhand
der Bilder die wir hier gesehen haben es
reicht eben nicht jeden Tag in der
Shisha Shisha Bar Razzia zu machen und
vor den Augen der Öffentlichkeit
sozusagen zu präsentieren wir tun jetzt
was wir tun jetzt was ist richtig aber
vor vielen Jahren ist schon
aufgeschrieben worden ich war selber
Teil einer ruhekonferenz habe da
mitgemacht und da ist aufgeschrieben
worden dass man nur für die Probleme im
Ruhrgebiet eine dreistellige Anzahl von
Ermittlerinnen und Ermittlern benötigt
wie viel hat es tatsächlich in NRW
gegeben 20 also 20 zusätzliche Stellen
auch mal so das heißt wir wenn wir
darüber reden was ist eigentlich zu tun
dann sind die Dinge auch schon lange
aufgeschrieben worden das wird es reicht
eben nicht mit Überschriften zu arbeiten
sondern es müssen hinter Menschen machen
weil die Straftätern jetzt rede ich mal
nur über die Straftäter und rede da
gruppierungsübergreifen sind ja mehrere
tausend über die wir gerade reden und da
müssen natürlich im mittleren und
Ermittler mit einem breiten
Erfahrungshorizont
zusammenkommen um diese Strukturen
aufzuhellen und die saufen in den
Ländern gerade deswegen ab weil es Gott
sei Dank gelungen ist durch diese
enkojetdaten also verschlüsselte
Kommunikation aus einem anderen Bereich
der organisierten Kriminalität wirklich
in die Tiefe der organisierten
Kriminalität einzutauchen über 4.000
Ermittlungsverfahren gibt es da in der
Bundesrepublik das heißt wenn wir die
Dinge beim Namen nennen wollen dann
reicht es eben nicht nur die
gesellschaftliche Debatte zu führen
sondern wir müssen sagen in den
Bundesländern fehlen die Ressourcen an
allen Ecken und Kanten und wenn sich
jetzt die Innenministerin hinstellt und
sagt wir rufen die Leute zusammen schon
vor vielen Monaten eigentlich geplant
eine Strategie auflegt mit sehr sehr
konkreten Dingen die alle in Arbeit sind
schon aus dem letzten Herbst dann finde
ich kann sich nicht an landesinnminister
rausziehen und sagen jetzt ziehe ich mal
die Arbeitsebene zurück und wir machen
dann nicht
verständlich aber die Aufgabe ist doch
viel zu groß
gestanden lächerlich sich da jetzt
beleidigt zu zeigen sondern hier müssen
tatsächlich alle zusammenarbeiten und
die Bundesländer haben da ein Problem
okay
ich möchte ganz ganz kurz wir laufen
sonst zeitlich aus dem Ruder dann
trotzdem noch mal zum Schluss gefragt er
vieler wo ist der wunde Punkt der
bundespunkt
die Kohle genau also und da gibt es da
will ich einen Punkt herausstellen damit
das nicht ihre abstrakt bleibt ich
arbeite selber intensiv gerade mit daran
die Bundesregierung arbeitet auch daran
ein neues Instrument zu schaffen was uns
tatsächlich ein scharfe Schwert in die
Hand gibt nämlich nicht die die Naivität
des Staates abzulegen und zu sagen es
gibt ganz viele Konstellation wo wir auf
Immobilien schauen auf Schiffe schauen
auf teurere Autos schauen und dann im
Prinzip uns nichts mehr dazu einfällt
aus welcher legalen Herkunft das
bekommen ist und dann zu sagen wir
schreiben in einem Gesetz mal rein was
Kriterien dafür sind was ein
Vermögensgegenstand zu einem Kriminellen
machen also aus Kriminalität stammenden
macht und dann wandern wir in ein neues
administratives Verfahren hat sich ein
bisschen sperrig an aber wir machen uns
auf die Suche ohne erst Strafverfahren
zu haben
rechtsstaatlich das geht wir nutzen
nämlich die Instrumente des
Zivilverfahrens und schöpfen mehr der
durch Kriminalität erworbenen Kohle ab
durch ein neues Instrument durch eine
neue Einheit die im
Bundesfinanzministerium gerade
erarbeitet wird dass man muss ja mal
über konkrete Maßnahmen sprechen und ich
glaube das ist ein scharfes Schwert was
nicht nur aber eben auch der clankriemen
tät sehr weh tun wird das sind sozusagen
wir sind schon bei Null aber noch ganz
kurz zum Schluss gefragt also dass der
konkrete Ansatz für die Polizei aber
trotzdem müssen wir uns doch ehrlich
machen hat er gerade mal nicht auch
einen Punkt auch mit Blick auf die
Ampelkoalition wie geht's ihnen wenn sie
dann hören das erstmal definitorisch der
Begriff planen geklärt werden soll bevor
wir dann über alles weitere sprechen
also es wird nicht erstmal der Begriff
geklärt ich hatte gerade schon gesagt es
wird ja schon eine Konzepten gearbeitet
bevor der Beruf erklärt ist weil
politisch leisten Entschuldigung ja das
ist keine Debatte das ist ein wichtiger
Aspekt um damit die Polizei ein
sozusagen über dasselbe reden das ist
einfach eine triviale story was sie
jetzt meint dass es manche politische
Farben gibt die wollen den Begriff
Planke mehr täten nicht benutzen dann
weiß ich nicht so das hat damit nichts
zu tun das sind zwei unterschiedliche
Debatten einmal operativ zu sagen wir
definieren das verstanden genau aber die
politisch leisten uns auch im Jahr 2023
immer noch genau diese Debatten ja bin
ich jetzt nicht dabei ehrlich gesagt
also
Phänomen
erlebe ich bei uns jedenfalls auch dass
alle darin interessiert sind will ich
handfest Instrumente zu schaffen damit
vorangeht okay